[Music]
to get started with a cloud natural
language API for nodejs you'll need a
GCP project which you can setup in the
console next enable the google natural
language api for that project then
create a service account and download
the private key as jason you're going to
use these credentials to access google
cloud api's so keep this file secure and
out of your code and public repos to
access the credentials from your project
go to the terminal and set an
environment variable to the path of your
service account prepare your environment
for nodejs development then install the
client library if you use cloud shell in
the console you can skip the step since
the required dependencies are already
included make a new project file or open
an existing file import the Google cloud
client library and then instantiate a
client
provide some text to analyze I'm going
to go with a classic example here now
create a document which has a field
called content set to the text you are
analyzing in a field called type which
as the name suggests is the type of text
in our case plain text call analyze
sentiment passing the document this
function returns a promise
I'm calling results which resolves to an
array the first element of the array is
an object representing analyze sentiment
response analyze sentiment response has
three properties document sentiment the
overall sentiment of the input document
language the language of the text and
sentences an array of sentiment for each
sentence in the text define a constant
for the sentiment of the document log
the parameters of sentiment score and
magnitude score is a sentiment score
between negative 1 for negative
sentiment and positive 1 for positive
sentiment magnitude is a number between
0 and infinity which represents the
absolute magnitude of a sentiment
regardless of positive or negative score
finally include a catch block to handle
any errors save this file and run the
code if everything worked properly you
should see the original text a sentiment
score and a magnitude in the terminal if
not take a look back at the code for any
syntax errors congratulations you've
just sent your first request to the
natural language API but there is more
that the cloud natural language API can
do like analyzing syntax and annotating
text to find out more about the client
libraries consult natural language
basics or a work through the sentiment
analysis tutorial check out the cloud
documentation
you